we have a voicemail number 2192 David P
speaking of cancel culture here's Peter
from China saying I am a counselor
hi David this is Peter from China yeah
on your recent show you once again said
that cancel culture was something that
didn't really exist and we should quote
push back against the concept of cancer
culture end quote
so David a few months ago when you were
encouraging your audience to call their
cable provider and complain about Fox
News being among the channels provided
what would you call that if not cancer
culture
or was that just a case of activism
going too far no it wasn't either many
people don't realize that they if they
have a cable subscription are sending a
few bucks to Fox News people who dislike
Fox News are funding Fox News many
people don't realize Fox compared to
other networks is more funded by cable
fees your cable fees than by advertising
relative to other networks so I told my
audience if you're displeased with Fox
News you can choose to make your voice
heard if you don't want your money going
to Fox News you can call your cable
provider that's not cancel culture
that's me telling people if you want
there to be consequences to the things
that Fox news is saying and doing you
can choose to call and tell your cable
provider you don't want to pay for Fox
News this is exactly the point this
isn't cancel culture it's consequences
to the actions of people based on the
things they do and say I don't know how
many times I have to repeat it but Peter
from China doesn't seem to get it we
have a great bonus show for you today
we're going to talk about my pillow Mike
lindell's RNC cam chairmanship campaign
we will talk about lawyers ready to sue
on behalf of three students over that AP
black history class that Ron DeSantis
wants to cancel and 70 percent declines
in one month of AD spending on Twitter
what on Earth is happening over there
get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at
joinpakman.com I will see you then